everyone loved the Ronnie Rose I noticed
in the email the people who got the most
let's say likes or the most positive
comments were two people Nikki Glaser
and Sal prevalence Wow they loved him
how could a guy that's stupid it's so
good and I mean this is a compliment
how could a guy that with that low of an
IQ with that kind of thinking process
how could a guy that stupid be so
fantastic
well that's reaching a potential I mean
how could he even come up with the joke
this guy thinks he's a turtle who is low
it's not low it's normal on the lower
side of no I'm complimenting you in the
same breath I feel great I didn't know
this was an open casket that was grab
the open casket line I wrote on the
train that yesterday morning Wow cuz I
was thinking like Ronnie and like shiver
and I thought of like mourners Kaddish
stuff like that look at you God is
another culture she's actually learning
a new culture Robin I'm in shock when I
want to resuscitate me this could send
all of us over yeah I mean you deserve
kudos right Fred he was on fire the
other joke that got a lot of thumbs up
was the Michael Vick joke I opened it an
animal hospital Michael Vick
Wow the place was wrong I noticed all
the comedians eyes lit up
I've always loved jokes yeah and you've
taught me a lot Howard you know I used
to listen to you every morning on the
train and listen to you and your style
and your delivery maybe I should make
you my son proud of you today thank you
thank you everybody yesterday you know
that he's gonna go off and disappoint
you and he'll do something stupid
few days from now I say something like
Pizza reah
[Music]